everybody welcome to live coding with
Jesse I'm Jesse today we're going to try
to turn our react project into a
progressive web app I've just upgraded
to next 7.0 point one and that's
probably the only change that's happened
to this project since the last time I
stream other than I did merge a few pull
requests I know some of you are getting
those hacked Oberer fest PR Xen so thank
you for everybody who's who's helped out
on that and yeah I think what do I do
yeah so I've been at the react advanced
react training with Ryan Florence so I'm
thinking of I might make a video recap
of what I learned there and put that on
my youtube channel so if anybody's
interested in seeing that you can check
out my youtube channel the links in the
description of this video I'd like to
get that done within the next day or two
before I start to forget things and also
I want to thank everybody who has been
helping out and sending me job openings
I have three interviews coming up in the
next two days and one phone call with a
recruiter so a lot of a lot of stuff
happening and I have two more interviews
that are need to be scheduled so they're
like most likely going to happen we just
haven't set a date yet so as of right
now that I'm thinking like five
interviews will be happening in the
month of October and I'm still waiting
to hear back from a lot of a lot of
companies so anyway thanks again all
your your advice and your links to jobs
and things have been super helpful and
I'll keep you all updated as everything
you know happens with that okay let's
get started
let me flip my screen here and if you're
new feel free to ask questions
we go along I'm gonna take breaks
periodically and go back to the live
chat and answer questions so just be
patient with me and I will eventually
get to your questions okay so nothing to
see right here for now let me let me
bring over that lighthouse audit and we
can start from there so if you've never
used lighthouse I'll give you a little
overview so if you go into dev tools
let's make this bigger much bigger okay
so if you open up dev tools which you
can do by just I mean there's multiple
ways I guess you could get there there's
a keyboard shortcut
I cannot remember what it is but you
could also just right click and go to
inspect it'll pop open these dev tools
and then up at the top if you click on
audits it would take you to the audit
page and you can run different artists
for like site speed accessibility search
engine optimization and you can also run
one for a progressive web app so this is
what I've just run and I got a 64 it's
not really a good score so number one
I'm not registering a serviceworker and
that's a big deal you need a
serviceworker for a progressive web app
so that's where we're gonna start is
making sure we get that serviceworker
register first after that then we can
look at some of these these other issues
about having the proper icons and things
like that you can see some of the other
stuff we actually have already and I'm
just going to show you this so that you
all know what what's needed cross
browser right we have that some of these
are just basic that you usually do for a
site anyway let's see each pages URL we
do have some and these some content even
when Java scripts not available
we have SSL so we use HTTPS we redirect
to HTTPS
we have fast load times even on a 3G
network the address bar matches brand
colors that's interesting
no that was that was the thing until
just now so that's kind of cool we have
a meta viewport tag content is sized
directly for the viewport yes so all
those things are checked here in
lighthouse for a progressive web app
there's a lot of links to learn more as
well so this is pretty helpful it should
tell us it tell you everything you need
to know let me oh the shortcut is ctrl
shift I to bring this up so thank you
Wow water room I have I'm sorry I'm
mispronouncing your name but anyway
thank you so much for the shortcut and
that's on Chrome I do want to say I see
a lot of people saying hi so I just want
to say hi to everybody I'm not gonna go
individually since there's so many but
let's get started
and first what I want to do is let's go
back to our code and I'm doing this on a
separate branch I made a separate branch
to install the latest version of next in
case it broke something this is not on
master and I'm just going to keep going
with all our changes on the same branch
and then if we if everything works we
can merge it back into master hopefully
at the end of the stream if we get it
working Oh Oh Bo says we could use f12
as well okay cool all right so let me
bring over some documentation as well
here we go and I'm gonna paste a link to
this so I just pasted this link in there
so you can read this documentation too
but I was doing a little research and
this seemed to work so there's been an
open issue on the github repo for next
j/s for at least a year and the issue
has been about offline support so you
could do progressive web app stuff so
this was one of the latest
trees one of the latest posts on that
long thread and it supposed to
regenerate a serviceworker that can help
next the work offline and somebody else
used tried it and it worked for them
so I'm gonna try it as well so the it
says down here that there's been some
updates for next seven so that's why I
thought you know what I better upgrade
to next seven before it so now that
we've done that let's install this see
we need to do to get it working so this
is next offline okay cool so let's go
back here let me make this a bit bigger
for everybody and we're using yarn so
we're going to do yarn add next offline
you can do this of course with NPM as
well that shouldn't take very long to
install while that's doing its thing
let's look at the first step so we need
a next up config yes which I think we
already have so let's double check that
we have that and we know we have a gest
config we not have a next config
I guess not okay so we're gonna have a
next config whoa right okay
it's what way Rupe I'm pretty sure you
told me how to pronounce that before I'm
really sorry that I didn't remember it
well ray wha wait Roo I'm gonna try
really hard to remember okay
let's copy and paste this now and
hopefully this is finished
yep it's finished and let's make you
know root here a new file we'll call it
next dot config dot J s and we'll paste
that we just have here so we're
requiring next off line and we're
exporting next huff or with offline so
save that and go back over we already
have a server J s file so we need to
integrate this into our existing server
da ji so I don't think we'll be able to
just copy and paste this let's see
actually you can add your custom next
just configuration as a parameter okay
let's see what we're doing here creates
let's see where they're actually adding
in with offline
yeah that's interesting I don't actually
see them using this anywhere let's check
out our server JS file and see if see
what's there
our server dot JS file was unusually
long and needs to be refactored but
we're not gonna do that today
so check out what we're doing okay so we
are checking for a serviceworker okay
looks like we only have it in this spot
okay so if it's the route is
serviceworker j/s we are skipping a lot
of our custom logic which I believe
that's what we ought to be doing and
we're falling back on next now I'm not a
hundred percent sure that's what we
should be doing so then all I'm
scrolling here I forgot we had this
giant object at the bottom okay this is
our our caching
all right since compare sir said like
listen okay so we have this if path name
is serviceworker trying to figure out
where exactly we need to put this
and sustained after society
okay I'm gonna look back just to see if
anybody's commenting anything about this
code okay you know what I forgot to
start up my appointment where a timer so
I'm just gonna keep an eye on the time
so no maybe in another let's say 10
minutes I'm gonna go back and answer
some questions in the live chat so just
hang in there for about 10 more minutes
I'll set this timer for for 10 minutes
so I'm thinking we may be able to take
some of this I guess I should double
check and make sure that everything
still works before we take another step
it looks like it works okay just make
sure you have pathname because first you
are
I don't think we're using the same names
for some variables so we need to find
the equivalent okay so app next
it's sick we don't need to do this right
now we we headed it let's come in these
out we left these in from a previous
thing we were going to implement and I
never took about so let's just comment
these out for now next why so
okay so app should still be the same
let's take all of this now let's just
take this out let's take all the
Salesforce stuff out this file is
already long enough okay realistically I
don't think I'm gonna be at this
position long enough to even implement
that so I'm gonna take that out and if
they ever want to put it back in it's
already and get up okay so we're done
kid
all right so this is all this custom
logic that we've done but what we really
need is what's getting just like passed
on so at some point we're just passing
things on to next and saying okay next
you just handle this
well okay so here is we have URL and
we're using that it's the cache key
sorry I'm trying to figure out what all
this is we made this so long ago she
handle app requests get requested
handler okay
now let's put in let's try to put some
of this in in here
oops I mean to take that massager
get rid of that okay
I'm hoping that's what I need was a
joint is not defined and parse is not so
fine okay let's see what we forgot there
we are
see if that fixes everything
in weird errors no no weird errors I'm
getting a new warning when I upgraded
that we shouldn't have title tag in
document j s so I'm not sure where we're
supposed to put it but I guess that's
not it's no now they're showing a
warning before they weren't okay let's
check out our page here we go I'm gonna
go to localhost to check this and just
click around okay it works try some
other pass okay all right that works
let's check in the console to see if
we're getting errors
okay we're getting some extra stuff here
about service workers so we should be
able to check out our service workers
here and see okay so for localhost test
a push motion okay so we have something
going on here with a service worker so
to test this let's put in what I don't
remember the command for this g-cloud
yeah
oops you know what I have this in my
package JSON so let's check out the
package JSON that right now like that
and our package JSON we have test the
floor all right yeah let's do test
deployed so that way we'll deploy to
Google App Engine and we'll get a test
URL but it won't push to our main URL so
the reason we want to do this is because
we're when we're running this on
localhost we're not gonna get a true
progressive web app experience where the
service worker is not gonna work as as
we wanted to so let's do urine what was
it called test deploy check the time
okay so while this deploys I'm gonna
start answering some questions and let's
go five minutes of answering questions
and I accidentally started that video so
at some point I'm gonna have to hit the
enter key but other than that that
should just do its thing
okay I'm scrolling all the way up to the
top I'm gonna just go through as many
questions as I can
I doubt I'll be able to get through all
of them in this
five minutes so though the rest will
have to wait until the next break
actually a lot of the messages are just
telling me I had no sound at the
beginning oh let's go through those and
[Music]
okay and about it the other half of the
messages are people just saying that it
works now the audio works okay Abraham
says hello can you hear me I'm in
California dreaming about who we used to
be thank you for that that was nice
ririn says please teach me about
programming yeah if you have questions
like any specific questions please let
me know I'm happy to answer them yes I
mean says I can't understand please
please clear and brief yeah I'll do my
best to explain what I'm doing as I'm
doing it and feel free to ask any
questions that you have
and I'll do my best to answer those pink
says what this guy does is pretty
advanced in my opinion I don't know I
mean advanced is relative right so to a
beginner this might seem advanced to
somebody who's been doing it for a while
this might not so it and we are all over
the place so sometimes we do really
basic stuff and sometimes we do advanced
stuff
Israel says I'm new to programming and
this seems huge yeah this project we've
been working on since like December or
January so it it has a lot to it you
know but it's to be expected to be
working on for a long time
Shang says hello Jesse good to see you
again oh it's good to see you too thanks
for joining us
lambs tech says Pomodoro timer yes using
a Pomodoro timer okay heart should sing
good to see you are should glad you're
here but the heart is saying don't
directly copy that code and is meant for
vanilla no and instead you instead you
serve it up get your utica stress there
hmm sorry disrespective what's that
coaching lessons to please
uh-huh I currently don't do any
interactive coaching lessons maybe I
should think about doing something like
that okay
i harsh it's put in some code here for
me to use so I'm gonna as soon as the
timer's up I'm gonna check that out
J says 243 lines the biggest code I ever
wrote was 80 lines so I haven't even
started a code from the look of it yeah
I don't we have a lot of we have a lot
of code we've been working on it for a
long time so don't be discouraged
somebody just asked what a web okay drew
asked what a web app manifest is it's
just a set of instructions to tell I
guess like the phone like what logo to
use what title to use what splash screen
what colors to use when you are loading
a progressive web app on a phone
Harshit says next offline automatically
generates serviceworker and prod see
okay that was in response to Michael
Creole Michael had said you might want
to make the serviceworker jazz file
first and Harshit saying it
automatically generates it yeah so it'll
we shouldn't have to do it ourselves XDS
how old are you I am 32 and I will be 33
at the end of this month okay so I'm
gonna go back to the code and I'm gonna
remember to start my timer this time so
in 25 minutes I'll go back to the chat
we should have a URL I guess not we
should soon have a URL but I'm gonna go
back and check based on what what harsh
it was was putting in the chat and check
and see how badly I may have messed this
up let's see server kid source workers
yes respond certificate
oh you know what actually this ended up
working so since I didn't copy and paste
the whole thing I ended up putting it
inside a server get anyway so it's a
little bit different so what Harshit was
saying is just get that serviceworker
Jass
and instead this is getting everything
that has been passed through which our
serviceworker jas should be passed
through since we were passing it through
up above so since that's going to pass
through instead of checking for it here
we just check for it down here right
because our path name is our parse URL
or parse URL is just the the URL that
would have we would have been able to
get through here so this should be the
same thing I should let me know if it's
not but I believe it it will end up if
the same result okay let's see here's a
URL
and what we do when this URL loads for
our test site and up I'll paste it in
here so y'all can check it out if you
want when it loads I'm gonna do another
light house audit and let's see if
anything has changed in regards to the
Service Worker where my thoughts all
right so you can do all these audits but
since we're just testing progressive web
app it'll take a lot less time if we
only check for this but you can check
for them all at once if you want so
we're gonna run those audits
and while we're waiting now check the
live chat
hamro says I'm 17 and dropped out what
should I do
well if you're interested in programming
learn as much as you can about
programming
try to get some freelance jobs maybe
with some small businesses and build up
your your portfolio and learn as much as
you can on your own like take the free
code camp lessons and you can still you
know get a good job you can make good
money from doing work like that saying
since the other day I was trying to set
up Express j/s as well as browsersync
does it make sense to do both I'm trying
to make a site to use this Express Jass
at the backend yep uh Express yes would
be good for the back end but browsersync
hey cool we passed sweet so we do
register service worker we respond with
a 201 offline awesome so now we just
need some icons and a splash screen cool
I guess I'll finish answering this since
I started already so as far as I know
and correct me if I'm wrong
anyone that is more familiar with this
but browsersync is going to allow you to
get like auto refresh and see what's
happening as you update things when
you're in local development Express is
going to actually run your back and like
even in production it's it's gonna be
the server right so you can you should
be able to do both I don't know that
I've ever used browser sync with Express
I mean usually it's I use Express in the
context of react and all that stuff's
already configured because I'm either
using next or i'm using create react app
by the way create react app 2.0 is out
so if anybody's use that and wants to
let us know how it is that I'd be really
interested to hear that I actually can't
wait to use it
that the next project that I do alright
so let's try this so we need these icons
let's see what icons we already have
because we do have a manifest.json
already where'd my code go okay so let's
check out our manifest JSON which I have
up here okay so we have a short name a
name we have some icons but not all the
right sized icons so let's see we need
okay we need icons at least 192 pixels
and at least 512 pixels
so let's add this in from now and see
just mean color background okay so we
have what we need there let's try to
make some images I wonder if there's an
automatic generator let's say
progressive web app icon generator sweet
I knew it had to be out there somewhere
right so we'll choose the file great and
then we'll get all these files there's
got to be a logo so you can have a logo
file no I don't want let's check it
downloads
see I uh I gotta have a little go in
here already right
and of favicon what is it that okay this
will actually work yeah that'll work
let's use that desktop all right it's
not really that like big enough we'll
see how this goes
might need to find a bigger image yeah
so you're padding all right let's see
what happens
I don't know what why do I have the Box
check for Windows Phone
does anybody have a Windows Phone oh hey
or [ __ ]
thanks for stuff for joining and
stopping in for a little bit
I appreciate it so see you next time
wait what happened it's not spinning
anymore which is happen
okay evidently that is not working well
let's try another one because there are
a bunch on the list
cool
so let's check out these app images
all right cool I think we have all the
sizes we need I'm gonna see if I can
just drag them over here to our static
files put them right here and maybe in
our images folder okay
it would not let me copy and paste I'm
gonna to mega dragon all right cool so
you have all these icons now let's see
if it gave us it did not I was hoping it
would automatically give us what we
needed
okay that's all right won't be able to
put this in here let's go to our
manifest.json and just switch this up
I'll leave these and then let's just add
in these sizes which or whatever ones
they said we need so we need at least
192 so here we have a 192 and that is
static image icon 192 192
[Music]
how they copy everything
I don't need everything okay to have
that and then this one will be our 512
and I'll copy this oops I mean copy the
path pop that in get rid of this okay
wonderful
I'll leave the rest of these sizes in
here just for now in case you want to
add those in but otherwise probably good
idea just to clean them up you know
overall your there's less size to the to
what gets uploaded to the server okay
that looks good to make sure that was
hit 150 or 512 and 192 let's see that
with the manual checks our page
transitions don't feel like a block on
the network he's fishing you're all okay
that should be it all right so let's run
this again so we're gonna run this and
I'm going to answer some questions while
that runs shake my timer and movies will
give it a check we'll run our our
lighthouse again and then the final test
will be I will actually try to load it
on my phone and you all can do the same
too because I'll copy and paste the URL
maybe that was fast
folks you know what that's I need to
stop my I need to stop my local server
before I do that because it could mess
up the build so we're gonna run that
again but anyway I'll give you the URL
you all can test it out on your devices
and see if it actually works and so if
it works in lighthouse and it actually
works on a device
then I'd say mission accomplished the
web says hey Jesse I am a beginner in
react
should I take any paid courses you could
it depends on your finances right if if
you can handle paying for course then
there are some good courses the Udacity
react nano degree is really nice because
you you have people that it will review
your code for you and let you know what
you need to do to to make it pass or to
make it better so that's very valuable
there's also like I just went to an
advanced react training from Ryan
Florence and that was also helpful as
well but you don't need to
most of my react training has been free
videos you know tutorials and just
reading documentation so it kind of
depends on how much money you have and
what your learning style is some people
do a lot better if they're in a
classroom setting with somebody talking
to them other people do better just kind
of learning on their own and all
different types so that's more like a
question that's going to depend on on
you personally the web says what's the
top state manager for react redux for a
long time was the answer to that
question but now like Apollo has state
management built in if you're using
graph QL that's a good choice
there's the context API that's built
into react now that can help you with
state management mob X is also good so
there's a lot more options now than
there used to be the follow-up to that
was which one is difficult context API
Redux or mob x of the three I I would
say Redux is harder to learn but it's
potentially the most powerful so if you
had a very large application that needed
the power of redux
then it might be worth it but if you
have something smaller
just use the
in context API and you know try out mob
X and see if you like that - it's also a
good choice alright let's test this out
and I'm gonna copy and paste this in
here for you all okay so the link is now
there and let's try out our lighthouse
audit let's try to console cool no
errors in the console that's awesome run
the audit and I'll answer some questions
while that's running manual says what's
the best way to save my data from my
database to my serviceworker we may be
not right to your serviceworker but you
could certainly use local storage and
the browser if you had a lot of data to
work with you might want to use
something like CouchDB so if you're
familiar with CouchDB pouches like the
browser equivalent of that and they can
sync together in real time so you'll
maybe check that out there may be some
other options out there but that's what
I would go to first V web says do you
know back-end programming I do know some
back-end mostly with node so we do like
that old server JS file like that's
that's backend stuff Anthony says what
do you mean by progressive so the term
progressive web app is specifically a
term that it's a web app that can work
offline and then progressively enhances
so more and more features will become
available as you have a better network
connection so that's because it's
progressive enhancement as we read the
way it progresses from so the basic
things that your app can do should be
able to be available offline when
there's a no connection and then your
the full range of features can be
available when you actually have a good
connection so let me know if that makes
sense
Wally says hi hey how's it going her
shirt says so I asked our [ __ ] earlier
if the way I did it would work and he
said yeah that's that's not the Express
j/s way of doing it but it works alright
will do I very much am a believer in
like when you first approach a problem
make it work first then go back and do
it do it right right so we'll make this
work and then we can always do it right
later feel free to submit a pull request
if it really bothers any of you and you
want it to be done right that's that's
cool cool so this passed so now let me
try I really don't want to type that out
on my phone I hope autocomplete handles
this if it doesn't then I'm gonna like
share this link with myself and so I can
click it
hey I think I think it did autocomplete
no it was an earlier version it's not
the vision I want let me copy and paste
this I'm gonna share it with myself with
Google keep
cuz that syncs up really fast let me
know if any of you have any luck getting
this a run locally I'm interested to see
how much of it is actually available
offline so I'll probably put my phone in
airplane mode after I load it and see
see what we can do
I didn't think about this what I already
pasted this into the chat I could have
gone to YouTube instead of going to keep
on my phone oh alright so wish I could
share my screen now wit which should
happen and maybe I would have had to
have done something else to get this to
work but it should prompt me at some
point to load this as a progressive web
app but I can't remember what point
that's supposed to happen
or if I need to do something else to
make that happen
if anybody knows let me know okay so it
hasn't prompted me yet so I'm gonna
manually do this so I'm just gonna go in
and Chrome on someone an Android phone
and in Chrome I can go to the menu and
there's an option that says Add to Home
screen
so I'm gonna do that option Add to Home
screen and let's find it so it is now on
my home screen so I should be able to
click that and it'll pop up now here's
just the test let's put the phone in
airplane mode alright so my phone is now
in airplane mode I'm gonna completely
exit out of the app and I'm going to go
back in and see if it still works
alright so some stuff still works so the
YouTube videos obviously don't load
which that that makes a lot of sense but
I can still like click on the tabs so
I'll show you like what I'm seeing so
this YouTube videos doesn't work but
these tabs still work the data is still
there for the home page the images are
still there so these
images are there but that that needs
formatted differently alright so that
works now I'm gonna try the menu menu
works now what I'm not sure about is
when I click one of these is anything
gonna happen
I'm gonna guess and say nothing's gonna
happen but let's see okay yeah if I get
an error that says it failed to fetch
okay but here's what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna take this out of the airplane mode
and then I'm gonna try to go to a few
pages then I'll put it back on airplane
mode and I want to see if it if it will
actually load then so you know what I
want to see is will it save these pages
okay so I've loaded three pages now I'm
gonna put it back on airplane mode so
I'm sorry if this is really boring for
you all because you can't see it but I
just don't have anything set up right
now to share this okay so I'm on
airplane mode now I'm gonna go back to
the home page and try to navigate again
to the pages that I just went to
hmm interesting okay so one page did
save but the other ones didn't that's
kind of weird
okay so I'm not I have an idea why I did
that but I'm not 100% sure so the only
difference I could see is when I put
this on airplane mode and I try to visit
a page that used the link tag without
the I believe without the prefetching
somehow it worked is I get cash that but
to menu let's go back to the code I'll
show you in the code what I'm talking
about so I I remember it in my mind but
I'm sure it won't make sense to you
unless I can show you so in the drawer
menu you can see we we have this link
URL and then we put this as URL in as
well but in our is our index so these
are the ones that didn't didn't save it
didn't work offline even when we had
loaded them online first but where's my
pages but these ones did work where do
we have index
a tab section you get a tab section
component so in our tab section we
actually have we're not even using the
link tag we're just using a regular link
so when I say the link tag I mean it
comes specifically with next J s and
allows you to do prefetching so these
ones stayed cached but the other ones
didn't so I don't I'm not exactly sure
what's going on there but the home page
still works offline and we at least some
pages still work offline so I'd say like
I'm not a hundred percent satisfied with
that but we have like very basic
progressive web app functionality so I
wouldn't expect every piece of content
to be available because that's just way
too much I wouldn't want to you load up
all that stuff on somebody's phone and
have it saved because they probably
won't need it all but there may be some
basic content that always should be
available so maybe I'll have to figure
out how to do that if that's possible
to just say I want certain pages to
always be available I'm not sure how to
do that but I assume it's possible so
that'll probably be the next step for me
if I want to continue on with this I'm
not sure how much value there isn't it
right now I as far as I know nobody's
really attempted to use the site like
this yet so if I can get some analytics
or data to show that this is a feature
that is being used then it might justify
me going in and trying to make it an
even better experience but in any case
you know we were so close to making it
work I thought it was worthwhile to just
do that a little bit extra to have this
work as a progressive web app so I'm
gonna go back and answer the remaining
questions now so if anybody is watching
and you have any questions about
anything at all please feel free to ask
them right now I'll answer as many as I
can and just to let y'all know I may do
a live stream on
my YouTube channel the links in the
description either today or soon
I'd like to livestream my studying for
the Google interview that I will have
somewhat time at the end of this month
so I'll probably do algorithm challenges
and I'll talk through it as if I was in
a real interview so try to explain
myself explain possible solutions and
then you all can ask questions and then
once I finish the algorithm I'll go and
answer your questions I think that will
help me to study and maybe it'll help
you all to see what kind of things you
should be studying for for technical
interviews as well so if you think you'd
be interested in that
you'll if you subscribe my channel and
turn on notifications you should get
notified of that and like I'd also like
to put out a pre-recorded video of a
review of the advanced react training
that I did last week okay I'm not sure
where I left off so let me scroll up and
see where I left off here okay I found
it
Antonio says hi I'm new here I don't
know any programming language where
should I start
it depends on what you want to do but
Java scripts not a bad place to start it
runs in the browser you don't need any
special thing to download on your
computer and there's a lot of beginner
friendly tutorials you could try free
code camp org start out with their
basics and you know see if you like it
if you have something specifically in
mind that you would like to do then
another programming language might be
good for you if you're in the machine
learning maybe you want to go into
Python if you're really into not
slipping my mind into like WordPress
development PHP might not be a bad idea
right so it just really depends on what
you're into but if you have no idea Java
scripts not a bad bad place to start you
can use it on the client and server side
it's a very versatile
viii webb says which one is better
Ubuntu or Mac I've only used the bun two
on a server so I haven't used like a
desktop version of it so I can't really
compare I will say in terms of servers I
I would definitely prefer to using
Ubuntu server than a Mac server does
anybody use Mac servers for anything I
know there they were a thing I don't
even know if they're used anymore has
anybody used Ubuntu as it for a desktop
and can share what would you think about
it as compared to a Mac now bill says
hello from algeria hey how's it going
thanks for watching awesome says I'm
also from Algeria cool to people from
Algeria awesome
bells Bev Cebu says what is the
frequency of live coding with Jesse it
used to be I tried to do every day now
not every day so I tried for like at
least once or twice a week things have
been different so if you want to know
what's going on with my work situation
right now what's the last stream the
beginning of the last stream and I
explained it all but things have just
been really different here recently so
that's been a lot of the reason why I'm
my coding has been not as steady so just
just check it out if you're if you're
interested blessing says I'm a beginner
so should I start with JavaScript or
Python I I'm going to answer the same
way answer the last question about this
it really depends on what you want to do
JavaScript and Python in my opinion are
both very easy to get into Python may be
even easier because of the fact that the
syntax is really easy to pick up and you
know there's not a whole lot of special
characters but like if you want to do
web development then definitely learn
JavaScript
if you're not sure then maybe your
Python a try Itachi says how
hey how's it going Kavya says love from
India thank you
I saw him says I really love how simple
Python it's simple and powerful yeah I
mean you got to love the Python syntax
right it just looks so clean it I mean
is really fun
Oh John says since you're on a Mac if
you have an iPhone you can copy on your
Mac and paste from your iPhone if you
have continuity enabled wow I don't have
an iPhone but that is really cool I did
not know you could do that my wife has
an iPhone Anna Mac I'm gonna tell her
about that and see if she's ever used it
I have a feeling I'm gonna tell her
about that and she's gonna say like oh
you didn't know that I've been using
that for years but I think that's really
cool I'm not gonna switch to an iPhone I
like my Android but that's that's pretty
awesome
Manuel says you need to set up the
serviceworker so it can load the pages
you add you can add pages serviceworker
what you want oh cool you know what I
never scroll down and read the rest of
this I bet you there yeah there are
options
yeah I'll have to check that out maybe
later but it's it's possible that there
are options for that here that I just
didn't read about
the web says what is the build system
that you use for production build react
app I mean next J s has its own custom
web pack config and it handles all the
build and then I send it to Google cloud
platform and it runs on their App Engine
the web says do you know nodejs yes I do
note we do a lot of custom routing like
form handling file uploads things like
that with node making like API close on
the background v web says what are the
best web technologies to learn right now
it that really depends on your goal if
your goal is to be completely on the
cutting edge like doing cool stuff then
you know maybe you want to work with I
don't know like web assembly and doing
like web VR stuff or like what else
there is up there I mean this isn't
really cutting as crazy stuff you can do
on the web if you want to get a job
there are a ton of react jobs out there
right now so I mean it just it really
depends on what would you want I mean if
you're gonna be on the web you need HTML
CSS and JavaScript for short you can't
go wrong with that they're not going
anywhere anytime soon they've been
around you know almost since the
beginning of the web so go with those
and if you're beginner it'll that should
keep you busy for a while trying to
learn those a master that beyond that if
you're looking at frameworks there's
still a lot of jobs with angular there's
there's definitely a lot of jobs with
react I'm not sure how many jobs there
are with you but view is pretty popular
at least among developers and then
there's some older frameworks that there
are still jobs for them you know they're
not really growing anymore but things
like ember you know there's there's
still jobs for that Nexus can PHP build
progressive web app or only JavaScript
well the key to a progressive web app is
that serviceworker which is a javascript
thing
it runs client-side so you could have
the backend be PHP but you would still
need to have that JavaScript
serviceworker so I personally have never
seen a PHP progressive web app but I've
also never looked for one so that maybe
they're out there V web says what are
the best courses to take in you to me to
learn react I don't know I've never done
a udemy react course so I can't I can't
help you with that but if anybody knows
have a really good one please let us
know I mean I'd be interested in it as
well Sergey says is PHP still alive it
is still alive I mean there are
evidently laravel is a PHP framework
that's getting a lot of like modern
updates I heard on a podcast recently
WordPress is still like most of the
Internet's and that runs on PHP so it's
definitely still alive while brew I
think I pronounced that right this time
says when should one use react native or
native code of a press a web app if your
site if you have a website and/or a web
app and your main audience is desktop
users but you'd also like to provide a
little better experience for mobile
users
I think progressive web app is good then
if your main audience is mobile I would
definitely go with react native you're
gonna have access to more of the the
features of like the hardware on a phone
then you would just using a progressive
web app so it's gonna be you're gonna be
able to build better phone experiences
with react native or just native code so
does that make sense
I mean there's definitely gonna be like
a line where you're not sure but like if
there's some feature on a phone that you
want to use and you can only use with
react native then you know definitely
that's
that's where you're gonna go but I mean
one of the the things to keep in mind is
like if you don't need those features it
gets take a lot of extra time and money
in terms of paying developers to build
out a native app but if you already have
a web app bill turning it into a
progressive web app but I mean we just
did it here like it's not that hard to
do so
you really have to measure like how much
value how much benefit am I going to
bring to the users like how much revenue
is it's gonna bring in if we do a native
app versus just progressive web app so
that's that's going to be a decision
that's going to depend on those those
factors the websites are you a wordpress
and PHP developer I do stuff with
WordPress I know a limited PHP to do
what I need to do in WordPress but I
wouldn't I wouldn't consider myself a
WordPress developer my my time spent
coding is overwhelmingly in JavaScript
Sergey says hi from Kiev how's it going
thanks for watching
Danielle says I used to used the bhutesu
every day but if there's a reason why
you want to learn go for it but it's a
headache sometimes ok dungaree says I
like turtles do you like turtles I do
like turtles turtles are nice V Webb
says I want to build a site like
Facebook can no js' javascript handle
that much traffic or I need something
else I would say you can go to a node in
JavaScript and if you ever end up with
as much traffic as Facebook you'll have
enough money to rebuild it in whatever
you want so don't worry about that
getting as much traffic as Facebook is
that would be amazing so you could
probably build it with whatever you want
at first and you'll have plenty of time
to refactor rebuild but you know as
you're on your way to Facebook like
numbers Manuel says what's your opinion
with angular
I think angular is good you can build
good stuff with it
I happen to prefer react but I haven't
used angular since angular 1 so I don't
think I can really give a good
well-informed opinion since I'm not up
to date on the latest in angular Jerry
asks if this is live yes in his life
Kabhi Kabhie and not should i pronounce
that says view is so easy to learn if
you don't know angular or react go with
you first I would suggest ok yeah I have
heard view is pretty easy so yeah if you
just want to if you want to get started
in something and build some cool stuff
then yeah view does I haven't used you
but it seems to be pretty popular and
straightforward V Webb says how much
time will it take me to learn myrn stack
it depends entirely on how much you
already know and how much time every day
you can dedicate to learning and how
quick of a learner you are so I it
really depends on the individual Bob
says can I use Django with you to have
real time app I suppose right I mean
he's just gonna be your client side
stuff so I suppose you could use it with
whatever back-end you want and Ray says
hi what about flutter you know what I I
know barely anything about flutter so I
don't I don't feel comfortable talking
about it because I don't think I can
give you good information right now
about that V Webb says can I get a
JavaScript job like react know to
express Cola without a college degree
yeah definitely at least in in the
United States you can I don't know what
it's like in other countries but you can
definitely get a JavaScript job without
a college degree Lee Webb says should I
go to college to take the time to learn
coding on my own well it depends right
if you want to be a web developer you
don't necessarily need to go to college
if you want to get into more complex
like math base things so more complex
computer science things so some more or
maybe the machine learning then the
computer science degree may help you
more
and depending on what company you want
to go to certain companies value
computer science degrees more than
others so check that out first before
you make your decision
jay-j I'm not sure I pronounced that let
me know if I'm doing it wrong but anyway
jaylen says hi from the Philippines say
how's it going a view web that's how I
get motivation to code if you're working
on projects that you like that will help
motivate you once you start to get the
hang of it and are able to do more that
will motivate you but the other you know
do what you need to do like drink some
coffee do some jumping jacks put on some
music that gets you pumped up right like
help yourself out a little bit you know
motivation is going to be different for
different people you know obviously but
the more you practice and the better you
get the more fun it's going to be
because you'll be able to build cool
things you'll be able to think up
something and build it and that's
awesome so you know more practice I
think will result in more motivation
right unless you just completely hate
coding but then at least you'll know and
you can start looking to do something
else the web says can I learn angular
react review in two to three months well
I mean you coding yeah the way I look at
it it's never like you're gonna
completely learn something because
there's so many ways to approach
problems in coding and even these
frameworks update frequently so there's
always new things to learn so you know
could you get to a point where you could
build you know functional apps with
those frameworks and libraries in two to
three months
yeah definitely you could you know what
I consider someone an expert after two
to three months probably not you know
but would I ever consider anyone as
having learned one of those completely
no if I wouldn't the web says I did you
learn coding documentation our online
courses and which one is better
it
depends Mosu learning coding was online
core is a mix of online courses and
documentation really usually when you're
just starting out documentation can be
confusing because you don't have a lot
of that basic knowledge to even
understand what they're talking about so
an online course can be good to start
out but then once you start to get
better with it it's actually much faster
to just go to the documentation and find
exactly what you need then to try to do
a course so at this point right now
unless I'm trying something completely
new I'd mostly look at documentation and
I remember whatever documentation was
way too confusing to me and my main
source was online courses so that
there'll be a shift that happens once
you get proficiency with with something
you know once you get really good with
something I'm not saying I'm really good
but once you get kind of good with
something then you'll be able to
understand the documentation more and
you'll find more value in it if he Webb
says are you in mobile development I do
react native stuff so not like mobile as
in like Cortland Swift Java but react
native mobile be web says thanks yeah no
problem there's all good questions
certain assess hi hey how's it going
bhakta says hi it's great to be live
with you is a bootcamp 15 weeks the best
way to learn coding I don't know if it's
the best it depends on the bootcamp and
who's teaching it and what they're
teaching and how you like to learn right
and how much time you want to dedicate
to it so I really think that this the
success of any educational program does
depend a lot on the actual student and
how much time they're willing to put
into it so if the student is a really
good student even a terrible program can
still be beneficial to them but if a
student doesn't want to put forth any
effort the great program is they're not
gonna learn anything so it's definitely
a mix so do your homework and get a good
program and then put the time
you know an effort needed to to do well
in it and then you'll be fine but it's
certainly it's not necessarily the best
way you know there could be other online
programs that are - bootcamp you know
self teaching so you know there are
options just you know kind of try to
figure out what's best for you and like
look back on your your learning
experiences and try to figure out what
helped you the most what you enjoyed the
most which you learn the most from the
web says what should I learn the psych
coding to get a job and any big company
communication skills are big like
writing skills because you probably need
to write documentation you'll need to
interact with team members with clients
so those are always important
do you use flow in your project and your
attitude static typing I don't use flow
static typing I think it can definitely
be helpful and help help you to write
programs with less bugs there so I think
it's if you have a really small project
sometimes it could be overkill just in
terms of like it's not 100% necessary to
keep everything straight but as soon as
you start to get a bigger size project I
could definitely see the value in static
typing need webb says when do I know I'm
good and react and can moves to back-end
development um when you can start
building stuff that's good you know when
when you can build things that work that
are useful to people then you're good
right if you can convince somebody to
hire you then you know you're good
enough right but you know you move to
back-end when you need to move to
back-end if you need to build out your
own back-end then that's the time to
learn it and you can certainly learn
react and back-end at the same time as
you try to develop
more complex apps you'll need more
complexity on the front-end back-end
cobia says I learned 30% of you from
courses on udemy 60% on my own project
and 10% I will hopefully learn by
improving my own project and doing other
projects in the future that's cool yeah
I mean I think that's it should be
expected right if you do a course or a
boot camp or anything like don't make
the mistake of thinking that like now
you know it it's time to move on like
now you know a little bit you're gonna
learn much much more by actually working
on things so you won't even be actively
trying to learn you won't be taking a
course or anything like that
you'll just be trying to get through the
day and and build what you need to build
or fix above and you'll learn so much in
the course of that without even
realizing it like I've wanted so much
over the past year through these live
streams of having to try to fix stuff
you know live and and figure out what
kind of pool requests are coming in
before I merge them and and really like
none of that had anything to do with an
online course or a boot camp or anything
like that it was just doing the work it
was you know we need to do this thing
I've never done this thing before so
let's try to get it done and you know
that's like your entire career as a web
developer or any type of programmer is
going to be learning and doing just the
constant cycle of learning annoying
undefined particle says are you familiar
with some place to look for challenges
or projects to move from the basic to
more intermediate level and let's say
JavaScript yeah you know what I don't
know what it's called or URL but there
are definitely like there are place
websites and I believe github
repositories that have lists of
potential projects that you could do so
I search for those there they're
definitely out there porec says I'm
getting advanced in mobile app
development but I see big companies
working on write once run on any device
and with simple web code can I mention
name I'm not sure what a bhakta said can
I mention name so I'm not exactly sure
what you mean by the question porec says
I really wonder if what I'm doing is
gonna be valuable long word what do you
think so you're saying like you're
learning like- app development as
opposed to something like react native
and I think native app development is
not going away right
it's they're still the majority of apps
are still native apps so I wouldn't
worry about that and those are actually
some really high-paying jobs I
frequently see native app developers
then the salary ranges are higher than
web developers psv n else has hello
Jesse I'm a junior web developer I want
to know that what will compare that
competitive coding will help me develop
better applications uh it it might not
necessarily competitive I'm not that
familiar with competitive coding I guess
it depends on what you're coding if
you're competing in like who can do
algorithms better that it would help you
that much it would definitely help you
in technical interviews but web
developers don't necessarily use a lot
of you know algorithm
types of challenges and things so I make
it depends on what you're working on but
I'm not sure I could be mistaken like I
said I'm not that familiar with
competitive coding bhakta says I learned
a lot very grateful oh I'm glad you that
you learned something so that's cool you
know definitely stuck back in for
another stream Sergey says what level
PHP knowledge do you need in the u.s. to
get a job I don't I mean I don't really
know I haven't ever really looked at PHP
jobs so I don't think I could give you a
good answer on that the web says so you
want any discord server or any social
web sites we can connect with you
I am I have my own YouTube channel it's
linked in the description
I have Twitter that I believe is also
linked in the description and I'm on
Instagram I'm also on Facebook but I
don't really do that much with it so
most active on Twitter and Instagram
Lee Webb says have you built any apps
with react native yes I have the web
says if I want to build Android and iOS
F should I learn react native or Java
Swift will be better you definitely be
able to build apps for both platforms a
lot faster if you go three-act native
then you won't have to learn multiple
languages new web says are you still
learning new web technologies oh yeah
for sure
yeah I mean I just got to use the new
suspense API that's not out yet
last week at the react training so you
know I'm always I'm always trying to
learn the latest stuff or at least the
latest versions of stuff like react
that's the job you got to stay ahead or
else you'll stagnate I mean to be honest
with you
I don't think I would have fun at this
if I just came in and did the same thing
every day and didn't learn new things
that's part of the the coolness of this
job is that it's always new right you
always have new challenges new problems
and you have to find out new ways to do
it and and there are new tools out so
it's like you can solve even similar
problems can still be different because
you use better ways to solve them better
tools better techniques so I I don't
know to me that's that's really fun not
everybody wants that some people want to
just want to job are you going you don't
have to think you put in your time and
then you go home and that's when you
live your real life I've had jobs like
that before there is definitely a nice
aspect to that I can see how people
could really you know be fulfilled by
that but I right now I really love this
and for the last six years I've loved
doing this and you know I have fun when
I'm when I'm coding but this is I've
started with JavaScript but not too
advanced level
now getting ready for boot camp where
the work is mainly Ruby please advise
hey I mean do your best and learn the
Ruby right if that's what you're going
to be doing in your boot camp so learn
that and you know
try to keep using javascript so you
don't forget what you already know
troll master says I can't get hired
because my real name on my birth
certificate is troll master Oh you know
maybe you can change that right or you
know maybe try to get hired at a place
that that likes trolls right you know I
mean evidently like reddit is full of
trolls isn't it maybe they'd hire you or
I don't know their YouTube comments
section is full of trove trolls I would
see if you could get in to build the UI
for comments and with Google for YouTube
maybe that's the place where you order I
actually never had problems with trolls
on my youtube videos
I wonder if just none of people even
watch them to care to comment but almost
all comments I get are positive and even
the ones that aren't positive are still
helpful it's Mel says thanks for the
good tips you're welcome welcome
hopefully they help some of you V web
says thanks Jessie I learned a lot from
you you are helping a lot of people oh
thanks for saying that
I hope so that's why I do these streams
and I will keep doing them as long as I
can as long as they are helpful to you
all so I've gotten through all the
questions we've had a about an hour and
a half of live streaming now so I think
now's a good time to stop I may end up
doing another live stream on my channel
sometime today we'll see how I feel live
streaming does tend to take a lot out of
me and sometimes I'll lose my voice so
we'll see how that goes but I'm not sure
if I'll be able to stream any other time
the rest of the week
I have interviews coming up and my
wife's having surgery so I have to take
care of her and the kids so this may be
my only stream for free code camp this
week I'm not happy about that I wish I
would be able to stream more but that's
just how it is this week so maybe I'll
see you next week maybe I'll see y'all
sooner
either way have a great day and a great
week and thank you so much for watching